mr. Dunn Bailey yeah welcome thanks for
having me
how you feeling in the UK good enjoy it
yeah yes my second time here not to
London I heard it's the only place I've
ever been in the UK before Manchester I
correct uh-huh yeah I was under Sam
SANNs gym that train yeah train yeah we
did we do dudes camp Josh rich and I
down there
good we had fun it was good walls you
know we spend a lot of time to GM
obviously booth so on Instagram
yesterday I saw Dave trying to put you
off during a photo shoot oh yeah have
you ever have you ever tried to just
sort of give him a little no Joe
whatever before he's got a workout I
like whisper random movements in his ear
we we go back and forth every now and
then on things like that but no I
Dave treats me like a little brother
sometimes so I appreciate it and you get
love doing it we have fun with that yeah
that's cool it's such a good into place
seeing you guys you're obviously such
good friends right and it I think that
seeing the guys there at the pinnacle of
the sport that are still so tight and
you can kind of see yourself and the
relationships yeah like it's really
really nice and I think that sets a
really good example for the community as
well I must feel empowering empowering
for you guys oh yeah absolutely it's
good to know you guys see that it really
really is authentic it's legit yeah so
can you talk to me about your changes in
training Styles over the years so what
you doing different now that you were
five years ago ten years ago sure I
think a lot of new CrossFitters like
right when I got in obviously it's like
volume volume volume you know you're
trying to play catch-up almost on all
these different things that you have to
learn
and then as you kind of get through some
of that you kind of start to figure out
how to do must loves how to snatch
properly how to you know you get your
technique down and your mechanics down
then some of that volume I've kind of
dropped off a little bit in specific
times of the year and focused more on
the quality getting in more intensity
getting in more simulations of actual
workouts that you're going to see there
in the open regionals or the games and
not so much of the beatdown tough to get
as much time under the curve may be yeah
yeah yes I mean in volume yeah they
build them a little bit more specific
yeah especially when you start looking
at like the regionals timeframe in the
regionals weekend is pretty set right
you know you're gonna compete for three
days and you're probably gonna do two
workouts a day maybe it's three scored
workouts but they're it's really one
workout that's crushed together or
something like that so as long as you're
training within those confines and
improving your weaknesses in those in
that kind of parameter you're gonna be
doing enough I guess that comes with
experience as well right sure
sure it comes with the experience yes so
Reeboks got a lot of bases covered with
its range of CrossFit shoes now so
you've got none else PTR legacy lifter
is there a shoe if you keep on finding
yourself wearing all the time I've loved
it I love the Nano I'm actually kind of
partial to speed TR really big fan of
any shoe that I can put on and go run
three miles immediately as well as it's
not gonna get torched on the rope I'm
pretty happy with I'm excited with and
that's kind of what I lean towards you
find yourself in those all of them yeah
I like being a little warm mobile and
that kind of thing knowing that I have
the capacity to go do my cross I guess
for yourself yeah so I'm a little bit
picky too when it comes to the shoe like
my foot has to feel right but you know
they've said Davis literally the
opposite like pushing on me as long as
it's a shoe yeah like he's good to go as
long as it's a left and a right I'm
sweet
right yeah see no I'll get a little bit
picky like I'll put it on immediately
start judging and that kind
yes just the way this what do you think
Donnie bro-flex thinks if in minato 8
he's really focused and he'd be really
focused in on one word it's right there
yeah I don't know if there's like a
subliminal thing they're like Reebok
might have done that on purpose I don't
probably for him do you think he would
have written he thinks it was yeah he
probably like look we can X out this we
don't really need any we've let's
emphasize the flex yeah that's probably
undulating he'd be a I want to talk
about your mental resilience after a
couple tough couple years yeah
can you talk to me about your mindset at
the moment and how it's being over the
last few years so in 2016 when I
actually when I just didn't qualify that
was the worst I mean that was the most
disappointing and I you know I had my
whatever two-week pity party or whatever
was and say okay you know what get over
it like you didn't make it it's what it
is move on and the thing that people I
think the thing that I was forgetting or
the thing that I have the easy way to
like lose sight of is that like a you've
been one of the best CrossFitters in the
world for the past five years no one can
take that away from you yeah you did
that like it's done and you accomplished
it and you didn't make it this year and
you didn't deserve to go like those
other guys did they beat you they did
better late I'll train harder train
better whatever you want to call it yeah
that's just the reality of it I'm a big
like coming to terms with exactly what
happened was exactly what the reality of
the situation is not oh poor me I was
screwed in this event or I
some of that might have happened but
just don't lost it doesn't matter - one
of the reason it's so yeah but in terms
of the resiliency I kind of look at like
the games is important to me and being
that athlete is important to be in the
fittest man on earth is always something
that I've been trying to do trying to
accomplish but there's so many other
things that I would like to be
remembered for like if I die and all
that's on my gravestone is here lies the
fittest man on earth in 20 and whatever
yeah I've been pretty disappointed with
myself I think I would look at that as
more of a failure than not making it to
the Games one year or never making it to
the games again so while it it sucks
that kind of you have to have a
short-term memory when it comes to those
things it's done it's in the past what
are you doing tomorrow I think that's
the other thing that's a really
admirable quality and I think that's
probably what makes you competitive to
being around for so long yeah
what's the coolest group shot that
you're in man there's a I'm in a cool
group check called Ohio till I die
right Ohio is the state that I grew up
in in the United States and it's not
very from the outside most people don't
think Ohio is anything but my friends
who I grew up with were real passionate
about Ohio and we have like a handful of
sayings that let's just like
everything's earned in Ohio like you
have to earn it
everything has to hurt a little more if
you want to accomplish the same thing
from Ohio
yeah whatever reason and we're big on
Ohio sports so state odd men right yeah
exactly like Ohio State football the
Cleveland Cavs Cleveland Indians and the
Cleveland Browns and Cleveland is not
known for being very good at any of
those things right but the Cavs are
obviously a shining spotlight the past
seen for years because of LeBron James
and the bronze from Akron Ohio which is
really close to where we all grew up so
anytime there's a Browns game or an
Indian's game or sit just non-stop
oh it's non-stop like I want to make a
book actually my buddy David Cooke he
brought up the idea of making a coffee
table book with like pictures from
Cleveland sports because Cleveland
Browns for those of you who don't know
are the worst American football
yeah statistically in history like they
are absolutely terrible but we have like
a die-hard like I don't care we're still
gonna root for you yeah but you're
they're just they're so bad it's
terrible couple more quick ones
have you tried 18.0 yeah I have not no
are you looking folks - yeah yeah I'm
gonna do it uh I had a couple issues
with my back recently and so looking at
that one that's like a red line wind out
oh yeah you know back smoke and if that
ended me yes felt so bad I'll hold off
but I will give it a try yeah you're in
The Hunger Games okay with only other
Games athletes okay who's gonna be the
hardest to kill you don't want to come
up against based on experience Josh
bridges for sure it's a time in the
military so he's got a particular skill
there that most people don't have yeah
LM in that my stuff is stone-cold killer
done though oh yeah this - like he'll
never get rid of that he's done he made
the shirt with his face on the back like
some camp is your image now yeah I don't
know who else I would pick that's such a
good question I'm trying to think of
well I think just I think Josh bridges
is is enough to end everyone's well he's
kind of the easy choice they're here all
right yeah final one would you rather
fight 20 duck-sized horses or one
horse-sized duck the 20 duck sized
horses okay even a moment huh
you're gonna Imam the horses the no four
time the time yeah they're just more
just gonna go bad Lenin yeah red lines
in red when you're talking about
fighting life or death like yeah 90
seconds of all-out fury that's gonna be
that's all I have come on clay he's so
yeah thanks for having me operation
really appreciate is my buddy
[Music]